gary's into this uh you know tracking
karen's the term karen according to
wikipedia is a pejorative term for a
woman seeming to be entitled or
demanding beyond the scope of what is
normal these are all summer cairns oh
this woman live streamed herself being
kicked off a royal caribbean cruise
after testing positive for covid this
one i call her a doctor karen there's a
lot of different kinds of karen's she's
a doctor cara because now she just
starts spouting medical uh knowledge
that she doesn't have right i had
coveted three months ago i have high
positive antibodies oh wait you're not
putting me in no ambulance i'm gonna be
in charge of my own [ __ ] life i'm
tired of royal caribbean telling me what
i gotta do when you're [ __ ] lying to
us you're [ __ ] lying
throw her overboard
she claimed that she tested negative
twice and then she said that royal
caribbean falsified her covet test so
she's a handful
here's another loud karen but this is
the one you named boohoo karen why'd you
name her boohoo karen i'm not even sure
what happened she was just in an airport
in texas and she was denied access to a
flight i'm not sure why but that's she's
like a loud yelling karen
[Music]
who saw him choke me to the ground who
saw me i saw you run through the door
when you weren't supposed to yeah
she wants the manager yeah the man in
the airport of the whole airport
bring him in
this is uh one more loud karen is this
the one from victoria's secret where the
woman has the tantrum she felt someone
was filming her and she did not like
that at all
people go why do you love jeff bezos so
much i go because you know what i can
get anything i want right delivered to
my house i don't have to deal with this
[ __ ] but uh yeah let me go out with the
karen's theme song
aaron can i please get a manager
have my first amendment right
go back to it go back to whatever
[ __ ] country you bought
the [ __ ]
why did you do that
stop it
that's illegal
i have done nothing illegal